a deadly amateur boxing match here in
the valley that made national headlines
will now likely force some changes for
the nevada state athletic commission
they're set to meet this morning to
consider some new requirements for
contests like the one that was put on by
a unlv fraternity last month it's a
story the i-team first broke hector
mejia joining us now live with the very
latest hector
good morning heather today's emergency
regulation being discussed was likely
triggered by that incident involving
20-year-old nathan valencia the student
died from head injuries just four days
after participating in that charity
boxing match last month unlv the kappa
sigma fraternity which held the event
and the nevada state athletic commission
are still investigating and we've
learned the athletic commission has no
jurisdiction over that event and here's
why the i-team uncovered that as of 1985
contests of unarmed combat conducted by
or participated by a school or
university were excluded from the
commission's oversight the emergency
regulation being discussed this morning
could change that it now proposes adding
requirements to exemptions relating to
those type of events commission chairman
stephen klubeck held a virtual press
conference after the i-team first
reported on valencia's death klubeck
points the finger at the university
with regard to
the university
having knowledge of this and accepting
and allowing this well go speak with the
university and the board of regents
they got a lot of explaining to do in my
opinion
they cannot duck hide bob and weave on
this
we made a request for a new interview
ahead of today's meeting but the
commission declined saying it was due to
the ongoing investigation we'll be
inside today's meeting which is
scheduled at nine this morning inside
the grant sawyer state building we'll
let you know what happens here on 8 news
now reporting live hector mejia live
local now